all right let's talk health the first
six months of a newborn's life is a
period of a rapid immune system
development
that healthy growth is dependent on a
delicate balance of good
and bad bacteria in a baby's belly a new
study suggests more than 90 percent of
u.s
infants suffer from a hidden problem
called newborn gut deficiency here's
more
the first six months of a newborn's life
are a period of rapid immune system
development
that healthy growth is dependent on a
delicate balance of good
and bad bacteria in a baby's belly a new
study suggests more than 90 percent of
u.s
infants suffer from a hidden problem
called newborn gut deficiency
here's more what this is is a
lack of that key critical good gut
bacteria
called b infantis that babies need
to help program their immune system and
gut microbiome
in the first six months of life as
doctors learn more about newborn gut
health the role of one particular good
bacteria
is becoming more pronounced as a vital
defense against potentially dangerous
bacteria
including e coli i recommend that my
parents
supplement every day this good
important gut bacteria it's called be
invantus activated
the infantis avivo is actually the name
of it and i have them mix it with breast
milk or whatever they're feeding their
baby
every day and we know based on data that
babies that are fed at vivo every day
have an eighty percent reduction in that
unhealthy bad gut bacteria
learn more at avivo.com